grazie
buonasera sono veramente felice di
essere in questo contesto bellissimo
sentire queste cose eccezionali non
veramente bellissimo
allora si iscrive scarto si legge tesoro
la riflessione ispiratrice che vorrei
condividere questo pomeriggio qua con
voi ma che vorrei da domani nelle vostre
case per me a sé anche un po la vostra
quotidianità e che riguarda la
convinzione ormai la quasi certezza che
si può costruire che si possa costruire
un'economia basata sul recupero e sulla
valorizzazione degli scarti della
produzione vegetale e questa economia è
un'economia basata sulla conoscenza
sull'applicazione delle scienze della
vita e permeata da tanta tanta etica
perché questa convinzione sempre più
forte perché ci sono diversi punti primo
punto primo dato di fatto esiste una
classe di sostanze studiata da anni
oramai in tantissimi università in tanti
centri di ricerca sparsi per il mondo
quindi che al suo attivo una mole di
letteratura scientifica accreditata
molto valida che ha tutta una serie
scusa di effetti positivi documentati in
questa letteratura ad esempio nella
prevenzione di alcune malattie vascolari
nell'opporsi alla progressione di certe
forme tumorali nella riduzione di
effetti negativi legati alla presenza
del diabete gli effetti del diabete e in
tutta una serie di patologie che
derivano da passatemi l'espressione
l'eccesso di fuoco mio vini nello
spegnimento di un eccesso di fuoco amico
che significa quando i nostri sistemi di
difesa troppo allertati sempre molto
troppo forse attenti certe circostanze a
combattere il i nemici a combattere
quello che chi deve essere combattuto
perdono un attimo l'equilibrio e
cominciano a rivolgere il fuoco anche
contro i tessuti contro gli organi di
cui fanno parte
ora queste sostanze vi rendete conto
sono sostanze straordinari ci hanno
delle proprietà davvero eccezionale
e altrettanto straordinari sono i loro
stabilimenti di produzione sperando che
non abbiate scarpe troppo eleganti
andiamo a visitare gli stabilimenti di
produzione di queste sostanze gli
stabilimenti di produzione sono possono
essere i vigneti delle zone tra aspi tra
astigiano e langa da cui provengo
possono essere i vigneti bellissimi che
ci sono qua vicino a verona nella zona
del valpolicella o i vigneti nei colli
piacentini del professor delle donne che
e di tante altre parti dell'italia del
mondo gli stabilimenti di produzione di
queste sostanze sono le vigne perché le
sostanze di cui vi sto parlando sono i
polifenoli estratti dall uva i
polifenoli presenti nelle bucce e nei
semi dell'uva cioè i materiali che
normalmente durante il processo di
vinificazione verrebbero scartati o
perlomeno sfruttati in scarsa parte
esiste esistono tantissimi articoli
esistono anche dei prodotti commerciali
a base di questi polifenoli negli anni
novanta nel 93 per la precisione sono
apparsi i primi prodotti per cosmetica
in particolare creme che servono a
combattere l'invecchiamento della pelle
contrastando lo stress ossidativo che
hanno al loro interno questi polifenoli
da da uva dallo scarto di lavorazione
dell'uva e ci sono tanti prodotti a
livello di nutraceutica ma ed è questo e
un secondo punto fondamentale di
riflessione grazie alla grande crescita
della conoscenza da una parte grazie
alla crescita delle possibilità
tecnologiche strumentali dei protocolli
di ricerca di tutto quello che che
significa test in vitro potenzialità
applicative e strumentali noi la nostra
azienda ci siamo fortemente convinti che
i tempi sono maturi per promuovere
queste sostanze per farne arrivare a dei
livelli tecnologici molto più elevati e
questo è un po a me piace molto questa
fotografia koldrup
di uva matura quindi durante il periodo
della vendemmia nella mano che
rappresenta la tradizione che
rappresenta un qualcosa di antico un
rito molto antico le nostre campagne e
mi piace pensare che questa mano stia
consegnando questo grappolo questa
tradizione quindi l'antico stia
consegnando questo grappolo alla
modernità delle colture cellulari vedete
nelle due diapositive alla vostra destra
ci sono cellule fluorescenti quindi
utilizzando queste possibilità
tecnologiche nuove queste possibilità
analitiche sempre più approfondite e
complesse e che la stia consegnando per
invitarla a studiare per invitare ad
andare oltre
quindi l'innovazione che parte dalla
tradizione e qui capirete che fatte
queste premesse fa un certo quale
effetto vedere che simili bio miniere
passatemi l'espressione siano quindi
vede gli accumuli di materiali
potenzialmente preziosi che potrebbero
avere delle applicazioni incredibili
sono per la maggior parte distrutti
perché chiaramente le linee cosmetiche
che sono disponibili commercialmente non
utilizzano una grande quantità di
materiali la maggior parte di questi
materiali ancora oggi viene distrutta
quindi vedere che un qualcosa che
potrebbe essere una splendida
opportunità in realtà è un problema e
come tale è da gestire quindi problema
piuttosto che opportunità introduca un
ulteriore punto di riflessione
io lavoro in azienda che si occupa
prevalentemente di materiali da impianto
nel settore odontoiatrico però reach è
un'azienda che ho sentito molte
sensazioni comune comuni al racconto
precedente nata questa azienda è nata
tanti anni fa con tante difficoltà
insomma prima di poter vedere una luce
positiva da un punto di vista economico
abbiamo dovuto lavorare tanto però
appunto con la passione con con l'amore
estremo per quello che facevamo siamo
riusciti a sopravvivere anche perché
abbiamo sempre fatto della ricerca di
soluzioni di applicazioni di protocolli
materiali di processi innovativi il filo
conduttore della nostra esistenza
quindi negli ultimi due anni ci siamo
trovati a voler sviluppare abbiamo
desiderato deciso che una attività
importante
voleva essere lo sviluppo di un
materiale che va che serve per colmare
difetti aussie per diciamo ripristinare
delle situazioni o se a livello dentale
che che sono un pochettino particolari
pochettino carenti ci sono dei difetti
delle lacune delle carenze che pensate
una volta potevano essere risolte con
dei prelievi di osso autologo dalla
sintesi mentoniero dalla cresta iliaca
quindi cosa molto cruente
oggi ci sono a disposizione dei
materiali di natura varie possono essere
sintetici o di origine animale che vanno
a compensare questi difetti quindi sono
molto spesso un importantissimo supporto
per l'odontoiatra che debba fare una
terapia impiantare in caso ad esempio di
assenza di osso oppure di problemi di
difetti allora noi negli ultimi due anni
abbiamo lavorato allo sviluppo di uno di
questi materiali che voleva essere un
materiale innovativo cioè non un qualche
cosa che semplicemente come potete
intuire da questa immagine viene messo
lì come il supporto quasi come parte
meccanica come sostegno meccanico per
compensare difetto noi abbiamo voluto
sviluppare un qualcosa di estremamente
innovativo in cui il materiale inerte e
le cellule parlassero linguaggio molto
più simile parlassero la stessa lingua e
e abbiamo fatto questo lavoro in maniera
come che che le cellule fossero attratte
molto di più molto più rapidamente in
maniera molto più efficiente su questo
materiale e quindi più rapidamente
producessero tessuto osseo mentre
sviluppavamo portava a termine questo
questo progetto ci siamo imbattuti in un
articolo di un autore di un'università
indiana che diceva che somministrando
polifenoli dagli scarti della
lavorazione dell'uva proprio testuali
e somministrandoli per via orale andava
a verificare a valutare ad apprezzare
anche una notevole note un miglioramento
notevole a livello dei processi di
rigenerazione ossea e allora il pensiero
laterale è stato ma perché anziché darlo
a somministrarlo per via orale
non possiamo questi polifenoli o
immobilizzarli nel nostro materiale che
va a sostituire a compensare il difetto
osseo e andare quindi a rilasciare il
sito laddove davvero servono perché non
esistono prodotti di questo tipo in
questo momento quindi fare diventare un
qualche cosa che finora utilizzato a
livello di cosmetica o a livello di
nutraceutica un dispositivo medico vero
e proprio
e allora cosa per questo pensiero
ovviamente ci ha tolto qualsiasi a
qualsiasi dubbio insomma siamo andati
alla ricerca
innanzitutto della materia prima che in
questo caso come vedete in queste
diapositiva è un insieme di bucce
macinate da uva barbera ma si possa
utilizzare anche altri vitigni questa è
una farina di bucce quindi qualche cosa
che verrebbe eliminato e poi c'è stato
un lavoro molto bello di estrazione di
isolamento di queste molecole attive di
questi polifenoli da questa farina di
bucce vedete anche che bei colori a noi
abbiamo solo utilizzati con queste
miscele acqua alcol e infine abbiamo
formulato diversi prodotti che potevano
essere in forma di polvere in forma di
pasta e abbiamo depositato la domanda di
brevetto per questo materiale quindi
dalla tradizione più antica dalla
tradizione delle nostre vigne grazie al
fatto di aver per un attimo invaso tra
virgolette un altro settore cioè di aver
attinto al settore della nutraceutica
abbiamo ci si sono schiusi mondi abbiamo
visto implicazioni che prima non avevamo
mai visto pur conoscendo tutte le azioni
benefiche dei polifenoli
eppure sen
immersi nelle vigne le vigne sono sempre
state il nostro orizzonte che abbiamo di
fronte la camera bianca del nostro
laboratorio da su una vigna bellissima
eppure non avevamo mai pensato fino a
quel momento di combinare la tradizione
con l'innovazione in questa maniera e
quindi il questo per dirvi che il
materiale in questo momento sta facendo
tutti i test
inizialmente i test di laboratorio
abbiamo già verificato che comunque
rispetto a qualsiasi materiale analogo
non simile perché materiali di questa
stessa tipologia non ce ne sono sul
mercato ma accanto a materiali che
dicevano la stessa destinazione d'uso a
una resistenza a stress ossidativo molto
maggiore e quindi ci sono tutte le
premesse perché questo prodotto a breve
veda la luce
del mercato e non è solo un prodotto che
vede la luce del mercato secondo me
secondo noi è un modello che che deve
prender piede che vedrà la luce della
ribalta perché è il modello di chi vuole
partire del prodotto che parte da uno
scarto e arriva grazie ad applicazioni
tecniche a conoscenze ai livelli più
elevati della difficoltà dei materiali
non solo questa convinzione aver
lavorato questo progetto ci ha convinto
che il modello deve essere anche
esportato ad altri settori che si può
pensare a un economia anche in altri
settori pensiamo ad esempio quello
tessile o tanti altri e abbiamo creato
un'associazione che si chiama innova
l'acronimo funziona solo in inglese
d'accordo in cui logo pensate questa
sembra un grappolo viola sembra un
grappolo d'uva
in realtà è un grappolo di cellule
infiammatorie che durante uno dei test
in cui mettevamo le cellule a contatto
con questi polifenoli si sono aggregate
in questa forma per me è stata quasi una
cosa foto simbolico insomma vedere
questo grappolo di cellule per
un'associazione che utilizza che che
vuole promuovere l'utilizzo tra tre
altre realtà industriali l'utilizzo
degli scarti della lavorazione dell'uva
non solo per fare prodotti ovviamente di
elevato contenuto tecnologico
non solo ma se vede che ogni porta c'è
un obiettivo che si raggiunge apre una
porta che in realtà ti porti una stanza
con tante altre porte
noi pensiamo e siamo sicuri anche dai
dati dalla base di tutto quello che c'è
in letteratura che lo stesso modello
economico che parte dal recupero degli
scarti dei semi dalle bucce dell'uva
possa essere applicato a tanti altri
scarti vegetali ed e questa può essere
la produzione media anche del pranzo di
oggi ho visto a un certo punto verso
fine del pranzo che c'erano tanti piatti
che avevano queste queste bucce se non
li guardiamo con occhi normali con occhi
non senza cultura ma con occhi comunque
in differenti da certi punti di vista è
solo spazzatura è solo un problema è
solo quello che le nostre
amministrazioni comunali che amano
organico residuo organico
se noi abbiamo un po di cultura
biomolecolare sappiamo che lì dentro c'è
un mondo di molecole estremamente
interessanti
se a questa cultura biomolecolare
aggiungiamo gli occhi biotecnologici
sappiamo che un insieme di molecole
interessanti per creare dei prodotti per
realizzare dei prodotti interessanti
e se a tutto questo aggiungiamo anche un
po di etica
sappiamo che sono molecole interessanti
per realizzare prodotti eccezionali di
elevato contenuto tecnologico per uno
sviluppo sostenibile grazie